so i was kind of uh hanging out in tom's
classroom playing a song of mine
and after the song is over he kind of
comes from behind the door
and he and he's like did you write that
song
[Music]
or mathias thank you for joining me on
20 minute leaders
it's actually matias and thank you for
having me
that's debatable okay so i have the
privilege of speaking to my brother now
for 20 minutes
one of the most incredibly talented
musicians that i
have ever met and will ever meet in my
life and musical director of broadway
juilliard nyu for musical theater and
now you're lecturing
at a university what are you doing just
give me a little bit of a rundown
these days i'm staying home and washing
my hands
as i hope all of your viewers are but uh
yeah it's been quite a ride i mean i've
like you mentioned i've kind of run the
gamut from from being in classical music
for many years to then working with rock
bands and pop bands and then kind of
finding myself at the heart of this
musical theater scene in new york and
now
uh have the privilege of teaching at
manhattan school of music which has been
so rewarding and
it's been kind of a wild trajectory
figuring out how to navigate
all of these musical interests that i
have and kind of uh
keeping things fresh and and really
trying to trust my
instincts in terms of you know letting
the road kind of take me
between these uh various paths and
figuring out how to
how to just learn the most from the
musical legends around me i think
definitely you know so i mean i'm coming
from the tech world an entrepreneurship
world
and the paths for a computer scientist
or an entrepreneur are somewhat clear
you know you you get into a good
university or in israel you go to a good
tech unit you start programming from an
early age and then you work as a
software engineer and so on and so on
how does it work in music so what do you
have to do to get to the level of being
on broadway
as a musician now as a composer and
being one of the top pianists in the
world
god that's that's really uh kind of a
million dollar question and it's i think
it's like the first question that i get
asked by you know these these incredibly
talented young people who make their way
to the city and
get started and want to know what the
path is like and i think the
the truth is you know there's this
there's this like
known um uh kind of phrase or adage
which is you have to be at the right
place at the right time but i think a
lot of it is
is just like being in as many places
during as many times as possible and i
think that
for me it was it was really making sure
that i wasn't pigeonholing myself
to one very very specific either style
or form of performance
or kind of idea of what i wanted to
pursue in front of me it was really just
figuring out how to
um how to really finesse the things that
sounded interesting to me
and i can be a little bit more specific
so yeah you know i grew up i grew up
writing songs and being inspired by a
lot of israeli songwriters and american
songwriters and thinking that i wanted
to be a songwriter
and so i you know spent my formative
teenage years
writing as many songs as i possibly
could and learning
and learning from you know the great
great songwriters
who i was inspired by their work and so
i did that for many years
and then weirdly you know when i was
when i was 16 and was living in palo
alto
um kind of found myself really
immersed with the dream of pursuing
classical music to the highest level so
then i
started practicing for hours a day and
really taking that seriously and found
myself at juilliard and
and you know did that wait wait so back
up what does it mean to practice four
hours a day
paint me a picture because you know most
people don't get to experience what i've
experienced growing up having a brother
that's all day next to the piano and
just doing scales on top of scales on
top of scales
give me the round now what is it like
yeah so that's
it's a great question and it's something
that i have to admit even for myself i
came to it a little bit
later than a lot of my um uh juilliard
peers who had kind of been doing it
since they were kids but for me you know
like a daily routine like you're saying
would would often consist of starting
the day with an hour of scales or
technical exercises
and that's something that for me was
really kind of the gateway
into the practice day it's warming up
the hands and stretching the boundaries
of what was possible physically
at the instrument working on things like
dexterity
working on things like precision and
making sure that
all the fingers were even in terms of
the way they were approaching the piano
so that's like
you know that's a very like kind of
methodical technical
uh form of practice and then you can
really
in terms of in terms of how those hours
are spent it's kind of amazing because
when you look at the idea of working on
a piece of music
you know there's the technical element
of being able to perform it so if you
think of
even even pieces that you know people
have heard of like rachmaninoff
concertos right so there's the element
of being able to play the notes
which which in and of itself is is an
enormous task and takes
hundreds of hours in order to finesse
but then there's also the element
of the musical work which is the
question of exactly how you're executing
each phrase
and that toy and the emotions you're
putting into it
right exactly and that and that is
endless and it's all about the
relationship between
how much control you have in a technical
level
in order to be execute the ideas that
you have
on a musical level and so that's the
relationship that you work on during the
practice session
but you actually when you know you look
at sports and you look at
let's say soccer you have some of the
inevitable injuries that people have
throughout their career
you had some some similar injuries but
from a musical perspective right
yeah i mean i remember your hands and
every and your back and everything
yeah it was so so the kind of the crazy
twist
um to like kind of the the arc that my
story took is that after all these
you know years of really practicing and
and and getting into juilliard and
feeling so excited i found myself there
and during my freshman year i was
so eager to prove myself that i was
practicing
tenfold and sometimes spending 12 hours
a day in the practice room
wow and a few months into my very first
year i started feeling these tingles
around my right arm
and it kind of went from zero to sixty
in a matter of days and found myself
with crippling tendonitis
and actually had to stop playing the
piano
for about six months i couldn't i went
back i
i was seeing this uh physiotherapist who
would allow me to
to practice for five minutes a day
and so there was this crazy moment where
i was in this like
epicenter of like the the greatest
musical institution in the world
and everybody around me kind of leaping
in strides and i was able to touch the
piano for five minutes a day it was a
very very
challenging to say the least period in
my life
unbelievable for the thousands of people
who wish they could be in juilliard but
you know because of its selectivity they
don't have the opportunity to be there
give me you know two cents of what those
four years were like
both the good and the bad oh
uh you open up a um a large can of worms
yes um so the good is certainly the fact
that you know i was at this institution
that gave me
gave me musical tools that i genuine i i
know for certain that i would not have
acquired anywhere else in the world i
mean it's unbelievable and the amount of
just like knowledge and technique and
understanding and depth
is something i draw on every day
right now when i write for theater when
i compose for various mediums
it's just this like amazing toolbox of
knowledge that i
acquired um the you know the the more
challenging side of the school is the
technical element
because part of what the school does is
it preps you
in such a profound way to be able to
tackle anything
under any circumstance with any level of
duress
which means that the expectations are
are incredibly high and the demands are
high and sometimes
sometimes it's it's possible to a little
bit lose
sight of the heart behind the things
that
you're working on because the speed
is so robust and so i will say for me
as somebody who came to school already
feeling like i was struggling to keep up
with the technical elements
it was hard for me to navigate the
demands and the passion
for the element itself no and i'm sure
that it's
that with all that you also have the
huge competitive nature
of any and any selective place where
you're competing at the end over
slots and you know the broadway industry
is notorious for being
for being what it is uh and then you
have this an incredible transition
and to doing your masters at nyu and
you're transitioning more to the musical
theater world
which is radically different from
classical music right
yeah what how did that even happen
um there's there's a story that i tell
and it um it sounds it sounds hyper
it sounds hyper dramatized but i swear
it's true um
and and we can we can have an alibi to
the story but the story goes that during
my senior year
um at juilliard i had this incredible um
a
theory teacher named thomas cabiness um
who
who i really really admired and
appreciated and i was writing all these
songs and one day i was
uh you know i would what what i would do
is sometimes before classes or after
class i would linger
in the teacher studios to just play my
songs because the teacher studios had
the best pianos
um and so i was kind of hanging out in
tom's classroom playing a song of mine
and after the song is over he kind of
comes from behind the door
and he and he's like did you write that
song and i was like yeah yeah i write a
bunch of songs that's one of them
and he hands me a piece of paper and
says something like
show up at this address tomorrow
[Laughter]
which which can be creepy but it was
also quite profound um
because the address that i ended up
finding myself at was
uh um was this incredible human name mel
marvin who to this day has become one of
my greatest mentors and mel marvin
in addition to being an unbelievable
broadway composer and wrote the music
for the grinch on broadway
oh wow also is one of the head composers
of this musical theater writing program
at nyu
and so we were at his house and he asked
me to play him a bunch of my songs
and i did and he just turned to me and
he said have you ever thought about
writing for theater
and i genuinely admittedly haven't i
mean you know we grew up in a household
in
in israel which was very cultured but
theater was not
musical theater wasn't heavily on my
radar um
and i said to him you know what that's
not really like thank you
but i don't really like that's not what
i do um and he said to me okay well have
you heard of this composer and this
composer and he started playing me
all of these amazing musical theater
songs by sondheim and adam gettle and
michael john lecusa all these people
and he said this is the music that's
being written you should check it out
and he encouraged me to apply to this
program at nyu
and at the time i was kind of you know
toying with the idea of maybe
going to l.a to do some film scoring
after juilliard etc but i said to myself
why not i'll apply
um and they very generously offered me
this um
uh this full scholarship this this
dean's fellowship to go to nyu
and get my master's degree in musical
theater and i said you know this sounds
like a great opportunity
and while i was there i met all of these
incredible people and started music
directing and and it kind of happened
you know serendipitously and naturally
um and unbelievable
yeah so i mean you've been in quite a
few productions on
on both on and off broadway you know i
remember
much younger i i watched you as you
played piano at rent
and you were i remember practicing for
hours for the last five years which made
me fall in love
with that show and in general you i mean
i owe it to you my love for musical
theater now and you know how much i love
musical theater arguably even more than
you do which is
which is quite ironic i have to say
given that i cannot sing and i cannot
play
and i cannot dance of course and then he
went on to
uh be a huge huge huge part
of the hugely successful show with the
great comet and you've really seen it
through it all right you've really felt
what it's like to bring a show
from ideation to broadway talk to me
about this
really unique experience that even most
people in broadway don't get to
experience
yeah kind of wild um
kind of wild so the story of my
relationship with that show
is kind of insane because i like you
said i had been kind of doing all of
this like playing piano and pits and
subbing
and rant and for the last five years and
and really trying to make my name as a
music director
um and i had music directed um a reading
and then theater speak
a reading is basically a week-long
workshop it's 29 hours in which you
basically just
workshop a piece to get it to a very
very basic form of presentation
and i had done this workshop for an
amazing amazing theater company called
arsenova which to this day
um has become kind of an artistic home
to me
and i i loved it and expressed to their
artistic director jason
egan that i wanted to be able to do more
with them
um and he said to me you know what
there's this guy
who we just commissioned the piece from
and
you should meet him i think you two
would hit it off because you both have
your passion about classical and jazz
and rock and come from all these
backgrounds and his name is dave malloy
and so he put me in touch with dave and
i remember i traveled to brooklyn and we
ended up sitting in this coffee shop
and talking about everything from bar
tom waits and to any kind of music that
you can imagine
um and dave had just started really
putting together
the final version of great comet for its
for its original production
and weirdly weirdly first invited me to
come audition
for one of the characters for bellaga
right
for bellaga who was at the time also an
associate
music director dave was also the music
director it wasn't enough that he was
the
writer book writer lyricist composer and
orchestrator he was also the music
director of the original production
um and and you know a lot of things were
happening with my life at the
time and it just so happened that i got
offered to go to australia and new
zealand for a tour with this violinist
and so
i i very sadly kind of had to withdraw
myself from the pool
of that production but i was following
it and saw you know it was it was
absolutely incredible
um and i was so honored that when the
show got picked up
um by a commercial producer and then
taken on to have a um
a commercial life dave called me and
said listen oh i should also say
um i also forgot that dave also played
the lead role of of pierre
right yeah that's correct yeah right um
and dave said to me listen
i think i think i'm doing one thing too
many i'm looking for a music director
will you do it and so i came in and
interviewed again with the team
um and i became the official music
director of the show and its first
kind of commercial off-broadway phase
which was done on
14th street right underneath the high
line
and it was this magical magical time
which i remember you came to see i think
there's even a
a photo of you young in costume
yeah yeah you dressed me up i was
sitting next to you i was feeling that i
feeling the power and you know we fast
forward and you all of a sudden you're
in the heart of times square on broadway
uh
with over a thousand people in the
audience in this very interactive
engaging production with josh groban as
the lead actor
and you know every time i still see the
good morning america
uh snippet of before you guys are
performing it just puts a smile on my
face and
all my friends who love musical theater
they just can't stop raving about
the great comet and the work that he did
there it was just so incredible
but you're not just a musical director
because you also were nominated for
for an award for being an actor acting
as
rachmaninov so funny that you're
mentioning him throughout this because
you're actually playing
rahmaninov and the lincoln at the
lincoln center right yeah so dave dave
wrote great comment wrote this
incredible piece called preludes which
was about
um specifically about a period in
rachmaninoff's life when he suffered
from writer's blog and i had the
distinct
privilege of playing in the show there
were two of us playing rachmaninoff
i played the pianist version of him and
my wonderful friend gabriel ebert
played um uh the kind of composer
troubled composed writer's block um and
yeah i had the i had the honor of being
nominated for
for a lucille artel award for for that
performance and
um that was that piece really had my
heart i loved working on that so very
much
incredible but your true passion after
all of this and with all of this so
you've already accomplished more than
like you know the top 99.9 percentile of
musicians could accomplish
yet your heart lies at composition and
artistically exploring
your inner life and the music that
you're creating is
very different it has a lot of right
jazz to it it has a lot of different
uh musical styling to it tell me a
little bit about what is composing to
you
yeah so like i mentioned i mean this all
began with me as a kid wanting to write
songs i mean i think you know one of the
um one of one of the big big big sounds
that was
in our house growing up and we
contributed this tour i think mostly to
our father
was was was cds of universe and his
wonderful israeli songwriter and mati
caspi and those were kind of like these
two titans playing in our house and i
remember hearing their music which is
infused with
with you know for mati caspi it's like
brazilian rhythms and for yoni rested
it's american jazz and it's these
amazing
harmonies with soulful melodies and i've
that's exactly the kind of stuff that i
love doing
so much and have wanted to pursue my
whole life doing and now i'm finally
you know i'm 32 and finally like taking
the time to say
all right i've done i've done all that
like really incredible
work facilitating other people's writing
and now it's time to go back and invest
in my own and so i wrote this
this musical called the wave um uh which
is based on this uh
really kind of harrowing experiment in
which a teacher turned a whole high
school into this fascist movement in the
60s
um and i've been you know developing it
for a few years with
uh with my fiance chloe treat who i know
that you also interviewed
um and we finally finally this year um
are getting a world premiere production
of it in austria
um and lynn's i mean you know knock on
wood god willing
world tour uh so world premiere of the
this musical in linz austria god willing
you know if
uh let's just hope the world starts
healing as quickly as possible but uh
uh it's just incredible so we're almost
to 20 minutes but i do have to ask you
the most important question
i need three words that best describe
you or
as somebody that you worked with would
describe you as
um i'd say okay
passionate um
uh i'd say
like hard-working or diligent um
and earnest earnest okay explain that
for a second
i feel like i i really believe in just
like
put it putting my heart out like just
being being
a true self i try to especially in my
work to not put up facades when i write
music i try to let it be
kind of the most honest and earnest side
of me
and sometimes just to allow myself to be
vulnerable even if not everybody
responds to it but to present myself in
kind of the
uh the purest form possible i love it
thank you brother michael